well I got to hang with Ben and his
fellow triple frontier cast mates for an
exclusive conversation which started
with a very very important topic thank
you for the beach photos we all saw them
we appreciate you're welcome bellies
they told us that was a private beach
when you saw them though was there a
dope or was there hmm
who knows there's the former yes I mean
they were humiliating there are no
speedos like Humira something on the
bottom yes marginally more humiliating
for you but still I got my share these
shirtless shots have been Charlie Hunnam
Garrett Hedlund and Oscar Isaac was our
first look at the cast together
I bought the bond I buy it completely in
the film but really and please tell me
that it wasn't all that good acting and
it was a true chemistry we were all
friends I've always wanted to be in a
boy band when this is like being in a
boy band if you had to be in a boy band
in real life which one would you choose
it's a that's an interesting proposition
because hard for me to think of a bit
like get in that boy band or I'll shoot
which boy band what I wanna you know I
haven't given this question much thought
the spike is surprising a lot of time it
comes up in interviews because there's
legendary boy bands in Boston Rob that's
true they go and ko TB for sure and sink
you know there's just too many acts to
be able to choose one the movie has our
guys playing former special ops soldiers
out to rob a drug cartel of Millions
do you recall a time when you have ever
worked that hard for some money for cash
[Laughter]
it's always a little hard and you think
it's going to say you walk out of here
and you trip over a big bag you open up
there's millions of dollars in that bag
what do we do take it to the local
police station Thank You charlie yes
that's right
I'd call Charlie first what do you take
it men no no come on I would reporter
what you call high-class problems it's
really heavy
there was no one sympathize with the
five of them together bananas such a
good time in by the way I saw the movie
I had palpitations the whole way through
in the best possible way trouble
frontier it's theaters this Wednesday
and it's on Netflix March 13th
[Music]